[Musique]
on vous a souvent dit que personne n'est
à l'abri des fausses nouvelles
mais comment on devrait réagir face à un
ami ou un proche qui a tendance à
partager ce type de contenu c'est loin
d'être simple et souvent très délicat
jeff on a besoin des conseils c'est très
fréquent de voir dans nos entourages
je ne suis pas tellement là un homme
s'appelle qui partage des contenus on
perd faut aussi qu'est ce qu'on fait en
ce talent qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
on s'est peut-être quelqu'un puis il
faut faire attention à comment on aborde
ce sujet avec la personne qui partage
quelque chose indique un très délicate
parce que quand partagent quelque chose
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est que ce
nouveau président sait qu'on y croit
donc c'est moins qu'on veut informer nos
amis notre famille c'est plus voici ce
qui s'est dit sur ma vision du monde
raison d'opinions exactement donc son
avis en veille soit vrai puisque
partagés souvent le réflexe et c'est
l'effet inverse donc la personne va se
braquer sur ses positions c'est parce
qu'on veut fondamentalement c'est la
paupérisation qui sont exactement
donc maintenant on veut aider la
personne à réaliser qu est ce qu elle a
partagé des pauvres et donc la commune
stratégie c'est vraiment n'est pas par
son public
léger en message privé donc écrit un
message trouvé sur facebook ou un
courriel ou même un appel téléphonique
ou encore mieux en personne personne
encore venu deuxièmement on fait
attention notre temps donc ça arrive de
partager les fausses d'information ça
arrive à tout le monde donc c'est pas si
grave que ça l'important c'est que les
personnes réalisent que ce pauvre est
qu'elles effacent la publication
officielle l'expliquent les échos
tout le monde peut tomber dans le piège
donc on se moque pas de la personne de
joseph garde ce que tu as partagé c'est
pas vrai voici une ressource convoitée à
comprendre
on reste poli et on essaye d'aider la
personne plus que de la confronter ou la
contredire directeur mais il ya des
degrés quand même hein il ya des degrés
de radicalisation mais aussi des
théories du complot ça ça peut aller
très loin parce que quand on dit
quelqu'un croit son opinion car c'est
une théorie du complot c'est du solide
oui parce que des gens qui croient en
théorie du complot ça devient en quelque
sorte
cette partie de leur monde de leur
identité que demain donc si tu arrives
dit à cette personne là voici trois
articles qui explique ce que tu dis
c'est pas vrai les personnes qui sont en
théorie du complot pense de cette raison
que les médias font partie ce complot se
videront tout on va pas réussir à les
convaincre
ce que tu crois pas dans ces colosses et
maintenir le dialogue avec ces personnes
donc souvent les théories du complot
vont avoir comme cible des gens qui sont
isolées malheureusement qui se
retrouvent dans isolé dans la vraie vie
ce que trouvent avec d'autres gens sur
le web pour parce que le service eu
aussi de cet univers
donc on garde le dialogue varions pose
des questions donc on fait juste deux
ans
pourquoi est ce que tu crois ce qu'est
ce que tu dis là dessus donc on pose des
questions et on l'en pour le but ultime
c'est que la personne se rend compte
d'elle-même que ces choses ne tiennent
pas la route
donc on peut lui donner des ressources
mais on sait vraiment pas dans le but de
lee ce ce que tu crois c'est pas vrai
c'est absolument pas vrai lice
une confrontation comme ça c'est pas
vraiment preuve c'est ça l'idée ce n'est
pas de faire la morale de le
culpabiliser les gens c'est juste
dialecte un peu plus de sensibilité de
jaser vraiment d'avoir un contact humain
si quelqu'un s'en proches ou quelqu'un
qui vous tient encore l'important c'est
de pas perdre sa ligne et d'être là pour
cette personne me font bien entendre